welcome back to peacemaking now since
putin continues his barbaric butchering
of the ukrainian people it begs the
question is now the time to take down
the tyrant 11 years ago this week this
tense scene captured the moment
president barack obama and his top
advisers watch the operation to kill
osama bin laden unfold in real time if
it's okay to take out osama bin laden
then why not putin and could it even be
done well joining me now is the perfect
person to ask former navy seal rob
o'neil a decorated special operations
soldier who fired the shots to kill bin
laden rob great to have you on the show
a real honor for me uh i've known you a
long time and it's an extraordinary
story that you have not just with that
operation but pretty much every other
great operation has had you with it so
thank you for joining us big question
people are asking big question people
are asking rob
could we take out vladimir putin one and
two would it be a good idea to do that
even if we could
i don't think we could take out
uh vladimir putin the way we did osama
bin laden simply because he's the head
of state he's got a lot more defense
he's got lines of security around him
you're not just going to be able to
sneak in there under the radar like we
did with bin laden and i don't think
it'd be worth
our interest in potentially starting a
nuclear war the way to get to him is to
go behind the scenes and i know we have
men and women in the intelligence
service that are looking for a coup
looking for some sort of assassination
attempt but unfortunately we here in the
united states have sitting senators who
like to get on television and say that
out loud because they're not really
worried about
getting rid of putin they're worried
about ratings for themselves so that
they can get campaign fighting so they
can get what every politician wants
another uh term and that's it but i
think the way uh is to through a coup
and i think they have something like
that plan coming up hopefully
when you look at what's happening in
ukraine as a military man
i mean you must be sick aren't you of
seeing these scenes play out on real
time on social media now which we didn't
obviously have in previous wars where
you see maternity hospitals being bombed
you see holocaust survivors being shot
dead in their homes you see refugees
being targeted as they try and flee with
their with their children what do you
think of it rob and how frustrated does
it make you well it's very very
frustrating because a lot of these
people that are taking other countries
to war aren't doing it for the reasons
they say vladimir putin said there was a
nazi uprising in kiev and that's what
he's telling the soldiers who are
massing on the border or they're doing
you know different kinds of drills uh
and they they've you know the ukrainian
people are defending themselves but like
you said they're being executed mass
graves there's death squads going in
there by the direction of vladimir putin
with no uniforms they can kill people
and take the spoils of war even right
now uh may 9th is coming up called
russian it's called victory day where
the russians you know beat the nazis and
they they're going to celebrate at mary
opal
they're having civilians clean up a
theater site where they've killed
hundreds of people in a bombing the
place where it said children inside they
had white flags outside they're making
civilians clear that out now right just
for food so they can eat so that the
russians can have a parade there and
show the russian people back home look
look we're winning look over here yeah i
mean it it makes your stomach churn the
the difference like the difference in
him and hitler is is one thing putin is
armed with a nuclear arsenal of 6 000
nuclear weapons and he's now starting to
use that in a very threatening way to
prevent people getting engaged with him
which is not supposed to be the point of
a nuclear deterrent how do you deal with
this new phenomenon of a nuclear power
basically using the nukes as a
protective shield to commit genocide
i mean this this is just proof that
vladimir putin has always been playing
the long game for mother russia there
was an agreement in the early 90s
between the uk the americans and the
russians that ukraine gives up their
nuclear arsenal that's a deterrent
in favor that the russians won't ever
invade and he eventually invaded and now
he's got the will plus he's also got the
terminal illness where he wants to go
down as a great premier one of the best
of all time and he's got the finger you
know a guy with dementia possibly two
guys with dementia on their their
fingers on the trigger and and they're
just throwing around the word nuclear
like it doesn't matter and to someone
that old that wants to be you know go
down in history
what's he got to lose i mean maybe he'll
do it it's very very scary what we need
to do is not just meet force with force
we need to meet that deterrent with the
potential of greater force and hopefully
people close enough to vladimir putin i
mean maybe soon when he goes you know
under anesthesia for surgery maybe he
just doesn't wake up who knows what
they're going to do because russians are
smart i hope they're smart enough not to
want to destroy the free world because
you got to figure
a missile from russia can be in the uk
in under 200 seconds i don't have the
exact exact math but it's fast
i mean that's that is a terrifying fact
isn't it and you know he is saber
rattling and the question is is he mad
is he bad is he both and how you know is
he sick we just don't know enough about
putin's state of mind to know whether
actually it's in his calculus to
potentially launch a missile we just
don't know do we
i think it's all three of those things
with you know his backs against the wall
he was supposed to roll through there
have kiev and then put put a puppet
government up you know like he did in
belarus when when you know someone won a
corrupt election if you can imagine that
happening in the world and and uh that's
what was going to happen they're going
to keep the ukrainian flag up russia has
that china rolls into taiwan it's all
part of the big plan but fortunately and
you know i don't i don't i don't think
that uh um
zielinski's the you know the
greatest hero that he portrays but he
was able to raise morale and it's
ukrainian people that are fighting back
obviously with some backing from us but
they're really showing what it's like to
love your country and to fight for it
that's the only good thing if you can
call it a good thing of this whole
conflict or war is that ukrainians are
showing you can stand up against tyranny
and you can defeat it which i think
they're doing well he's certainly
raising their morale and the people are
fighting for him and i think they see
him as an inspiring leader and you know
i remember as we as the anniversary of
what you did all those years ago i
remember being in new york i flew into
new york that night and i remember just
the unbelievable excitement that was in
the air when news broke that osama bin
laden was dead and then i had the great
honor of meeting you and shaking the
hand of the man that did it and i just
want to thank you again for what you did
because that was an extraordinary thing
and we're all massively in your debt so
great to talk to you rob always any any
time pearce great to talk to you guys